what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice so Jeff John
strikes again and holy hell dude
Doomsday Clock number 3 is so good it is
uh man it is it is incredible it's it's
it's an amazing story for those of you
guys who were just now joining us you
know if you if you're just kind of you
know hopping on this whole bandwagon of
Doomsday Clock Doomsday Clock takes the
Watchmen from Alan Moore and rolls them
over into the DC Universe and the last
video ended on like a pretty massive
cliffhanger which was the return of the
comedian because as we've seen in our
Watchmen video so far the comedian died
at the beginning of the story that's
kind of what set the whole Watchmen
story in motion was the death of the
comedian and so the idea is like you
know when he showed up in the end it was
okay who's playing the comedian like who
in the world is playing the role of the
comedian somebody's got to be playing
his character because I mean the
comedian's dead and he can't be
resurrected from the dead right well the
cool thing about this is that it
initially opens up with like the
comedian seemingly just kind of like up
hearing in the water in the DC Universe
you know out in the ocean somewhere of
course you know swimming to the surface
and and basically coming to and he's met
by dr. Manhattan now this is huge this
is massive on the surface it doesn't
seem that huge but this is huge because
he's wearing the exact same outfit you
know the bathrobe and everything that he
was wearing when he originally died the
indication here is that dr. Manhattan
intervened or resurrected the comedian
now I would say dr. Manhattan probably
intervened
if he resurrected the comedian then like
Eddie Blake would have just shown up
like on a street somewhere or in a
building somewhere but what it looks
like is at the time he was being thrown
out of the building when he was
basically being attacked in the
beginning of Watchmen and before he hit
the ground he was effectively teleported
away and we've seen that happen right I
mean that was the whole basis of the Oz
effect mr. Oz is the the father of
Superman he was supposed to die when
Krypton exploded but instead dr.
Manhattan stepped in and whisked him
away teleported him away from Krypton
and threw him on earth and then
basically forced him to you know percent
up receive earth and to see earth from
everything that was going on in the eyes
of you know just a normal person and so
on
so forth but the reason why this is such
a big deal is because it's been
established in the Watchmen at least in
the original box man watch my colleagues
dr. Manhattan cannot time travel he
can't travel back and forth through time
he can perceive time all you know all
happening at once and so because that
it's really intriguing because either
this means he has a new set of powers or
time is passing differently in the
Watchmen universe than it is in the main
DC Universe but again it's one of those
weird mysteries that goes on we don't
know exactly how all these pieces fit
together
it is really intriguing and it is really
interesting now the other half of this
is we're not really given a time frame
of when this is that comedian landed
here we don't know if this happened 20
years ago we don't know if this happened
five years ago if it happened you know
an hour and a half ago we don't know
exactly when this took place all we know
is somewhere along the line when
comedian was falling to his death he was
whisked away by Manhattan he ended up in
the DC universe and at this point we
pick up with his attempt to take out
Ozymandias now of course this leads to a
leads to him really you know trying to
kill Ozymandias because of everything
that happened in the whole Watchmen
comic of course kind of picking up with
the idea of Doomsday Clock and so on and
so forth did the other half of this is
that Lex Luthor was kind of caught in
the crossfire right like the killing
shot meant for Ozymandias was you know
ended up hitting lex luthor instead but
the fight that breaks out is pretty
intense and it's very reminiscent of
what we would expect in this kind of a
situation comedian versus dr. Manhattan
Ansari a comedian versus versus you know
Ozymandias and it is pretty intriguing
because remember Ozymandias is
supposedly one of the fastest people
alive if not the fastest man alive and
Watchmen because he was able to like
catch bullets and so on and so forth the
reaction time was unbelievable but again
it's kind of crazy because you know any
Blake starts talking about things like
how death changes a man but again it's
it's it's kind of a mystery year we
don't know how all this stuff fits
together now of course you know
Ozymandias is able to make his escape
Lex Luthor's kind of left behind oxygen
awesome and eNOS is injured in the fall
then at that point we pick up with
Rorschach and Batman and that was really
like the biggest cliffhanger of issue
number two was Rorschach meeting Batman
for the first time but remember this is
not Walter or this is not a you know
Walter corvex I don't know why I keep
saying corvex but it's been hinted right
off the bat or at least we've been told
white off the bat this is not the
original Rorschach
the two of them meeting each other is
really intriguing and so it's really
kind of Jeff John's hitting home at this
idea saying hey look this person is not
the original War Shaq but he does have
possession of war shacks journal and
this is cool because he basically passes
this information to Batman passionate
the journal to him and says you need to
read this you need to read this journal
and everything entailed within it now at
this point we pick up with marionette
and mine now remember marionette and
mime are like the old Charlton comic
characters again for those of you guys
who are relatively new while Marvel and
DC do stand is like the biggest and most
popular coming for publishers right now
with like valiant an image in a really
really close second what you also had
back in like way back in the day really
before Marvel became Marvel back when it
was like Atlas and maybe even timely as
you had Charlton publications and
Charlton created a lot of characters
Blue Beetle different things like that
and a lot of those characters are just
kind of rolled over into DC when DC
bought Charlton just because the fact
that Charlton couldn't keep up with DC
in terms of sales but marionette and
mime are these are you know kind of a
tribute to these old salt and characters
a design to kind of be a homage to these
old superheroes from back in the day but
for the most part when they when they
popped up people immediately got the
vibe of like de Joker and Harley Quinn
and it's designed to be that way
and the reason why is because when
they've been thrust into the DC Universe
they show up in Gotham City and it's
really intriguing here because once they
get into Gotham well then the question
becomes you know what is this place
let's explore the city and let's see
what's going on they basically make
their way to a to a bar of sorts which
is the Joker's bar and this is cool
because the Joker you know one thing to
keep in mind when it comes to to DC
Comics the Joker has these different
little places here and there use
different places he operates out of a
way to kind of build as revenue
different things like that to kind of
make sure that this stream of money
flows to a degree or at least to always
access henchmen and it is interesting
because marionette and mine don't know
who the Joker is but it is funny because
a fight inevitably breaks out here when
they kind of show up and they're like
look we don't know who the Joker is and
we don't really care we end up having
mine basically pull an invisible gun now
this is all new to me I mean this this
is new for the most part I mean this is
F is is really like uncharted water
where previously it was believed that
mine was wielding
invisible weapons or at least mining
weapons what he actually has are
invisible weapons he's got an invisible
gun he's got invisible daggers and he
actually shoots a person with this
invisible gun it's really cool and it's
really really intriguing because it kind
of throws people off you have a guy who
walks in here and it looks like he's got
a gun in his hand but in reality you
don't see anything but then suddenly the
trigger gets pulled as a flash of light
and somebody's brains are all over the
other side of the room so it's really
really interesting now of course these
two one of the things that that the
Geoff Johns hit home is the idea that
they're very sadistic they're designed
to be reminiscent of what we would
expect with the Joker and Harley Quinn
and so they tear all these guys apart
and they they literally crush every
single one of these guys and with
everybody having been taken out
everybody having been you know more or
less killed off the question they have
is who's this joker guy and let's go
find out who he is let's go see what's
going on with this Joker fella it's
really intriguing and it's super
interesting now from here we basically
pick up with well really with a lot of
ways Johnny Thunder and this is kind of
a big deal now Johnny Thunders a
character that we've talked about before
and he really kind of had his big moment
only really a couple of appearance
appearance is so far I want to say one
was in the button and the other one was
in DC Universe rebirth number one but
Johnny Thunder is a throwback to like
one of DCs oldest characters he really
is I mean he goes all the way back to
flash comics number one in 1940 so he's
been around for a long long time now in
truth the reason why Johnny Thunder is
so significant here or at least the
reason why I think they're invoking his
character is because Johnny Thunder is a
character that's in possession of what
amounts to basically a genie I want to
say his pronounces is it's like it's
like Y Z or something like that but it's
basically called a thunderbolt
when Johnny Thunder accesses this power
he basically becomes a reality warper
like it's insane how powerful he is he
can do virtually anything he wants to
now this is all pre-crisis stuff and
this is all stuff back from like you
know All Star Comics number 40 Q in like
1948 and
this is all old school stuff before
crisis on Infinite Earths now DC could
grab it and they could roll it over but
Johnny Thunder as we see him here being
an old man all indications is that the
post-crisis landscape for Johnny Thunder
is still intact meaning he doesn't
really have the Thunderbolt power
anymore he doesn't really have the power
of the genie anymore but it doesn't mean
that he can't it doesn't mean that it's
not possible for that to happen we've
seen him you know have it originally
then we saw him lose it Hakim picked it
up who was basically a post-crisis
character that was designed to kind of
reinvigorate and reinvent the character
of Johnny Thunder or at least the
concept of the Thunderbolt originally
Johnny Thunder is kind of you know
basically died and then of course he
came back to her in blackest night but
the fact remains that I mean it's
entirely possible that even if he's not
necessarily the one that would be in
possession of the is genie the
Thunderbolt power it doesn't mean he
can't get into contact who we know with
those who can but it is intriguing
because again we're talking about a guy
who has reality-warping power or at
least with the is genie would have
reality-warping power now all that
brings in a sharp relief the question if
the that power is that strong then like
what hope would it would they have even
against dr. Manhattan anyway because the
power of the genie was basically equal
to the power of mr. Mixel pedelec but we
saw in Superman reborn that mr. Mitchell
pedelec was terrified of dr. Manhattan
how many was that was one of the things
that was flushed out that missile you
know Mitchell petal-like had at some
point in time come into contact with
Manhattan and realized that even with
all his reality warping power Mixel
pedelec was basically dwarfed by the
power that dr. Manhattan had so again it
really kind of begs the question what
hope do they have but if they do have a
reality warper on their side then
conceivably they stand a better chance
than just kind of Superman fighting
against dr. Manhattan and hoping for the
best now this also brings into sharp
relief the nature of the JSA right the
Justice Society of America you know that
was really kind of like DC's way of
answering the question why is it that
Jay Garrick the original flash doesn't
exist anymore in DC said well I mean you
know all the superhero stories where you
see Barry Allen running around as a
flash that all takes place on earth one
all the superhero stories where you see
Jay Garrick as the flash that's all on
earth too and it was pretty simple for a
time anyway until really about ten years
later when I just turned into absolute
madness but it's well-established that
for the most part
jon's loves the Silver Age of comics and
rightfully so because back then it was
really more of like light-hearted
superhero fare as opposed to now when
the stories are a little more gritty and
a little more reflective of the nature
of the world that we live in and so with
the return of the JSA it would almost
seem like this kind of missing link in
DC comics would sort of be rounded out
it would be like if Marvel brought the
Fantastic Four back there's something
about the DC Universe that's just not
right it's just kind of missing that one
thing that really kind of sets it all
off you know Shazam is another character
who's missing Martian Manhunter there's
a handful of things that are out there
that would help to kind of complete the
DC Universe in the eyes of fans but in
terms of the impact of the Justice
Society it's bringing an era of comics
where hope is really the name of the
game that was the base that was the way
it was with the JSA and when you look at
things where it's like well because of
the Superman theory and because of the
fact that you know 97% of all the
superheroes originated on earth and
because you have all these different you
know programs out there the Russian
government that's using you know they're
kind of metahuman testing to basically
weed out people and arrest them and they
believe to be metahumans it's almost
like this idea that John's is kind of
going back to his you know the kind of
Infinite Crisis roots where this is a
criticism of superhero stories as a zhis
now I wouldn't say this is as
heavy-handed is Infinite Crisis but I
will say that it's kind of hitting at
the idea that either the DC Universe is
kind of going down the same path as The
Watchmen in the sense of the earth is
kind of on a collision course for
self-destruction or it's a criticism of
the idea that the world kind of seems
hopeless at the moment in the DC
universe that things are pretty dark and
what the DC Universe needs is a spark of
light they need something to kind of say
hey look guys it's not as bad as you
think it is and having old man flash Jay
Garrick you know having old man Green
Lantern Allen Scott having these
characters just kind of show up and
basically be this kind of beacon where
they sort of set the landscape and
they're kind of these other superheroes
that embody the hopeful concepts of
Superman would really kind of beef that
up a bit that kind of seems to be what
Jeff Jones is hitting out here now again
that's speculation online on body half
it's not really anything guaranteed is
not a solidified thing it's just kind of
how I look at it and interpret it
because you know as a person who is
really relatively new to DC I will say
that from what I've seen with people
commenting it feels like
thing is kind of missing and maybe that
JSA is you know the key
maybe I set a little puzzle piece that
would sort of flush things out in their
entirety at this point we switch back
over to Rorschach and again in this
story work Shack is kind of taking up
residence in Gotham I'm sorry Anna
though in Wayne Manor only temporarily
but what we end up getting is the reveal
of his face now we don't get a name here
all we get is a reveal of his face and
the indication is that he is actually
the son of Malcolm long that he is
actually the son of the psychiatrist of
the original workshop but we're not
given a name so we don't know for sure
the indication seems to be the play it
seems to be the case you know we knew
that Malcolm long had a son Malcolm long
and his wife for both african-american
clearly this version of of Rorschach is
african-american we knew that just
because of the reveal of his hand but of
course with the face and everything we
also know that's an absolute certainty
the clues are there and it really kind
of seems to be thrown in our face but it
could also be a red herring so again
until a name is dropped we're not given
an absolute certainty but you know that
kind of seems to be the case which we
can probably run with that we could
probably take that as some measure of a
gospel truth but the fact remains here
what we end up having is Batman going
through the entirety of the original war
shot journal and basically meeting with
you know this this new war Shack once he
wakes up after having slept for like 24
hours and it's intriguing because Batman
basically says hey look I think I know
where this guy's at like I know where
dr. Manhattan is we have to go find dr.
Manhattan and it's really really cool
because what ends up happening is he
says look I think this guy is in this
facility over here so like we need to go
check this out I'm pretty sure I know
where he is he leads were shocked to
this location opens the door Rorschach
walks in and all there is is riding on a
back wall that says we're all mad here
and Batman shuts the door behind him and
says look I'm sorry but you belong in
here we ended up finding out this places
Arkham Asylum that Batman believes
Rorschach is a crazy person and as a
result just locks him up and throws away
the key and that's what's so interesting
about this is because Rorschach's not
crazy and he is to a degree assuming
that this guy is anything like the
original Walter Kovacs like he is kind
of crazy to a degree but it doesn't mean
he's
a broken clock is Right twice a day and
this guy's basically coming with news
saying hey look the end is at hand the
end is nigh there's a being walking
around in your universe that Dwarfs all
the power that you have the events that
you experienced in the button that death
and eobard thawne being able to see your
father
you know this mysterious power source
out there that destroyed the White
Lantern Corps I know what it is and I
know what it's capable of but Batman
doesn't believe any of it to be true he
doesn't really think any of it's legit
and ultimately kind of calls it a day
Bruce Wayne has not connected the dots
now the question becomes what happens
when he does what happens when he
connects the dots is were shakka this
guy gonna break out and he's just gonna
kind of be gone is the trust between the
two of them what little there was going
to be completely shattered it's
interesting it's really really
intriguing like it's it's really really
fun and it's it's kind of a mind-blowing
ending to this story but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the Rob
Court you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you